there's mothers fathers senselessly died
in our street that their voices went in
her and now generations of pain is
manifesting itself in front of the world
and the world is watching one of the
first people I call that an advocate for
justice an advocate for reform but more
importantly an advocate for kindness and
decency and when I talked to Valerie she
said first and foremost seek justice
seek fairness and reach out show
kindness what the woman saw last night
was not that what the world has
witnessed since the killing of George
Floyd on Monday has been a visceral pain
a community trying to understand who we
are and where we go from here I'm joined
today by Attorney General Allison by
Major General John Jensen yet what the
world has witnessed since the killing of
George Floyd on Monday has been a
visceral pain a community trying to
understand who we are and where we go
from here I'm joined today by Attorney
General Allison by Major General John
Jensen yet to put something very
important this is the moment where we
start but every time we get to this
place
we never start the process to make sure
it doesn't happen again
and that commitment amongst leaders in
our community watching this happen
across the United States watching
another name be added and for those of
us who are old enough to Rodney King
Mike Brown and unfortunately now we've
added George Floyd the situation on the
ground doesn't allow us at this time to
tackle those issues the very assets in
our community our libraries our
businesses those of us who are old
enough to Rodney King Mike Brown
and unfortunately now we've got it
George Floyd the situation on the ground
doesn't allow us at this time to tackle
those issues the very assets in our
community our libraries our businesses
justices serve swiftly and that we learn
something from what George
Floyd gave on Monday not want to just be
very clear Tom and I have the team talk
about what transitioned last night when
the state assumed responsibility over
the security near the third precinct
where the state secured critical assets
and where the plan going forward to
ensure that tonight our buildings do not
burn our citizens are secure and that
space that we're going to create allows
us to get back to the conversation of
serving justice and making sure that
we're not adding to that list of unheard
names now I want to be very clear and
speak to that community if your critical
assets and where the plan going forward
to ensure that tonight our buildings do
not burn our citizens are secure and
that space that we're going to create
allows us to get back to the
conversation of serving justice and
making sure that we're not adding to
that list of honored names now I want to
be very clear and speak to that
community the very tools that we need to
use and get control to make sure that
buildings aren't burned and the rule of
law collapses are those very
institutional tools that haven't led to
that grief and pain I understand clearly
there is no trust in many of our
communities and the differentiation
between the matrix to a place where we
can restore the justice so that those
that are expressing rage and anger and
demanding justice are heard not those
who throw fire bombs into businesses
that our community colors have worked so
hard to build back
up areas that were blinded at one time
and are thriving because of their
entrepreneurship and their hard work a
library in an area where our children as
we know are institutionally put behind
and the achievement gap for our
communities of color is a shame on this
state that we continue to admire by
talking about and don't repair it and
that tool to help with that burn last
night so I want to just call out very
very clearly as we put a presence on the
street to restore order it is to open
that space to seek justice and heal what
happened
I will not in any way not acknowledge
that there's going to be that pain but
my first and foremost responsibility to
the state of Minnesota is the safety and
security of all citizens we cannot have
the looting and the recklessness that
went on we cannot have it as we can't
function as a society and I refuse to
have it take away the attention of the
stain that we need to be working on is
what happened with those fundamental
institutional racism that allows a man
to be held down in broad daylight and
thank God a young person having camera
to video it because there's not a person
here or listening today
that wonders how many times that cameras
not there these are tough questions
these are things that have been brewing
in this country for 400 years we have
people out there putting themselves on
the line to try and put out fires and
our firefighters that are under attack
those are the things I'm asking you help
me restore that order we will do that
under state leadership and state
guidance you will hear directly from
them once that decision was made around
12:15 last night and that first mission
was executed around 3:45 at the third
precinct
we will see a difference so I'm asking
you and you'll hear from them to talk
about this I also want to think about
what happens when we don't have that
people who are concerned about that
police presence of an overly armed camp
in their neighborhoods that is not seen
in communities where children of people
who look like me run to the police
others have to run from so I understand
that that's out there but last night I
got a call from a friend and a dedicated
public servant Senator Torres recalled
in her district and it was on fire and
there weren't any police there there
weren't any firefighters there was no
social control and her constituents were
locked in their house wondering what
they were going to do that is an abject
failure that cannot happen we must
restore that order to that senator
Torres Reyes bought her whole life on
these issues of inequities and making
sure that people's voices are lifted up
but what she understands is none of us
can lift those voices none of us can
tackle these problems it Anarchy Reigns
on the street I also want to address an
issue in this one is on me and and I
will own it
earlier this morning when this mission
was carried out under my direction to
re-secure the third Precinct to do so in
a manner
I am proud of how they was executed by
this team no injuries and no loss of
life a reestablishment to put the fires
out for those businesses a CNN reporter
was at Crewe who was arrested by the
State Patrol a few minutes after hearing
that I was on a call with CNN president
Jeff Zucker who demanded to know what
happened I take full responsibility
there is absolutely no reason something
like this should happen calls were made
immediately this is a very public
apology to that team it should not
happen and I want to be clear for those
of you listening
I think our Minnesota's reporters know
this I have a teacher by trade and I
have spent my time as governor
highlighting the need to be as
transparent as possible and out of the
press here I take full responsibility
there is absolutely no reason something
like this should happen calls were made
immediately this is a very public
apology to that team and should not
happen and I want to be clear for those
of you who listening
I think our Minnesota's reporters know
this I have a teacher by trade and I
have spent my time as governor
highlighting the need to be as
transparent as possible and have the
press here I think so to CNN to the CNN
team to the journalists here this is
about having a plan and that's what
these folks are going to talk about this
is about having an aggressive approach
to understanding what the community
needs than not coming in heavy
and with them but to create space where
the story can be pulled in a situation
like this even if you're clearing an
area we have got to ensure that there is
a safe spot the journalism
to tell the story the issue here is
trust the community that's down there
that's terrorized by this if they see a
reporter being arrested their assumption
is is because something's going to
happen and they don't want to be seen
and so that is that is unacceptable we
will continue to strive to make sure
that that accessibility is is maintained
that not only that the protection and
security and safety of the journalists
covering this is a top priority not
because it's a nice thing to do because
it is a key component of how we fix this
Sun Shine disinfectant and seeing what's
happening has to be done so again I
appreciate president subs call I
appreciate his understanding in a
situation that he was rightfully
incredibly angry and that falls squarely
on me that apology has been issued and I
think going forward to make sure it
doesn't happen again it's time for us to
cleaner streets it's time for us to
execute today in a way that shows
respect and dignity to communities I'm
going to ask for a lot of help today of
those folks who want to see it it is my
expectation then justice for the
officers involved in this will be swift
that it will come in a timely manner
that it will be fair that is what we've
asked for I have been in contact with an
open County attorney and I am confident
that those very things I just said will
happen we will continue at the BCA
to do a fair a full and a swift
gathering of all of the evidence
involved but I would reiterate again for
so many of us not all that's done in
every other case where all of that
evidence is
before and I would ask that the swift
justice be carried out so Minnesota's
your pain is real the chapter that's
been written this week is one of our
darkest chapters and we can choose a few
things we can choose to try to get past
this we can choose to put a force out
there and stop things from happening we
can hope that in the midst of kovat 19
or something else it passes by and we
don't have to turn that mirror to look
at the harsh reality of those underlying
gaps whether it be healthcare
disparities whether it be educational
disparities in our communities color
whether it be policing disparities in
our community of color whether it be
wealth acquisition in our communities of
color are all very real we pride
ourselves on the state of openness we
pride ourselves on a state of being
friendly I've talked a lot about one
minnesota that wasn't on display last
night I don't know easily think
everything heals and come to the
forefront and you say it'll be better
this is a community that demands and
should expect more than words they
should expect results lieutenant
governor Flanagan and I have tried to
make equity the center of everything
we've done but obviously in Minneapolis
on Monday night there wasn't a lot of
equity for George Floyd his family is
probably wondering where the one
Minnesota is for them
and that's on us us as Minnesotans us as
the governor and the team that works
with me to put the things in order to
establish order in our streets to
establish and rebuild trust in our
communities the one Minnesota is for
them and that's on us us as Minnesotans
us as the governor and the team that
works with me to put the things in order
establish order in our streets to
establish and rebuild trust in our
communities
governor Thank You Martha the kids said
many years ago that riot is the way that
the unheard get hurt
he didn't condone it but he said to the
nation as a person who always protested
peacefully that don't just dismiss that
and ignoring and relegated to just
criminality and bad behavior actually
ask yourself what's going on there and
is it something that we as society
absolutely must pay attention to I think
we must pay attention to it I like
everyone to to recognize the fact that
the National Guard just a week ago was
administering Coppa 19 tests to help
people to help people the presence you
see on the street don't react to them
the way you might react to the
Minneapolis Police Department it's not
the same group if different leadership
different Authority and their job is to
try to bring peace and calm back again
please remember that this is not the
group that you associate with unfair
conduct but it's a group that in fact
just a week ago was trying to make sure
that Minnesotans couldn't survive and
thrive and live because we are still in
the middle of a pandemic it is that
sense of service when they get involved
when it comes to natural disasters
storms floods rains diseases now they
have to restore it on order on the
streets and I hope that you the
community who is protesting will protest
peacefully but not see this as a as an
arc
another occupation by another military
force it really is make sure that
there's calm and peace and that
everybody can operate peacefully so
please accept that is that I am asking
that of our community it is essential as
it and I've said this before everybody
keeps asking the question when when when
when when and this is a this is a
perfectly legitimate question it is
important to know that under Minnesota
Statutes the primary jurisdiction for
criminal prosecution is with the county
attorney in which the offense occurred
and I believe that the message has been
sent and received that the wheels of
justice must turn swiftly not unjustly
expeditiously thoroughly fairly swiftly
it is important that people have
confidence that accountability no matter
who you may be is how we live in
Minnesota let me also say that this
prosecution this investigation this
criminal process is important in its is
it is and it is and the whole country in
the whole world looking at it cannot
solve the problem as the governor so
eloquently said events like this start
and they come to a conclusion but we
never start the process of real reform I
will submit to you that myself and
Commissioner Harrington under the
leadership of the governor have already
started the process on the working group
on preventing and reducing deadly force
encounters with the police we have a
report that we want attention from the
legislature the entire community on to
focus on that so that we can really get
to the bottom of this
it comes to issues of use of force when
it comes to officer violence when it
comes to community healing and a whole
range training issues all kinds of
things to bear on this issue and it's
not just those things we believe that I
believe that the real work of our cut
art working group is the implementation
of this and that really begins in
earnest now and is more important now I
think than ever so I just want to as I
conclude my remarks I want to say that
we issues all kinds of things appear on
this issue and it's not just those
things we believe that I believe that
the real work of our cut art working
group is the implementation of this and
that really begins in earnest now and is
more important now I think than ever so
I just want to as I conclude my remarks
I want to say that with mr. Floyd is
intolerable absolutely unacceptable and
must change that message has been sent
and received as well and good the
governor myself the lieutenant governor
all of us are committed to that long
term change and I can tell you that many
legislators will feel the exact same way
people in the philanthropic community
feel the exact same way so I think we're
gonna do some real change we're not just
gonna fix the windows and sweep up the
glass we're gonna fix a broken shattered
society that leave so many people behind
based on their historical legacy of
being in bondage and servitude then
second-class citizenship and now fraught
with disparities from everything from
incarceration to housing to wages to
everything else and so with that I would
hand it over to general Denson
general Major General Jensen who will
further elaborate thank you very much
good morning I made for General John
Jensen from the edge of general the
Minnesota Army National Guard and I've
been the adjutant general since November
2017 and what I'm going to describe this
morning to very quickly is the actions
of the Minnesota National Guard since we
were mobilized under the Governor
Waltz's executive order like many
Minnesotans I woke up yesterday morning
to the news that the Minneapolis Mayor
had requested National Guard support the
only difference was I opened up my phone
and there was a tax from commissioner
Harrington it wasn't the newspaper or
the morning news that notified me of
that
so immediately yesterday morning made
contact with the commissioner and we
began planning on the potential
employment of the Minnesota National
Guard in support of Minneapolis for
those of you that may not understand how
emergency management works in Minnesota
I'm just going to take a quick moment to
explain them in Minnesota County
emergency management coordinators were
the mayors of Minneapolis st. Paul
Rochester and Duluth may request
National Guard support through the state
EEOC
so in accordance with that in the
atmosphere there Frank made that request
the Minnesota National Guard what
traditionally comes with the request
though is a layout of capability needed
and exactly the problem that's trying to
be solved typically the request for the
guard and that type of information come
at the same time sometimes it lags so
when it lags we what we do is we begin
preparing for an unknown mission but in
this case we sort of knew what we might
be doing as it related to civil
disturbance in Minneapolis but it's very
important we know exactly what we're
being asked to do so we make sure that
we have the
equipment we mobilize the right number
of soldiers and the right number of
soldiers and airmen to support those
soldiers that are going to conduct the
mission that element was lacking but
with the governor's decision to allow me
to continue to plan we began in
notifying soldiers early yesterday
morning of a pending mission once we
notified our soldiers again with the
governor's verbal approval would begin
mustering our soldiers and moving in
moving them into the metro area knowing
that the most likely probability
probability of employment was going to
be Minneapolis as we as we met as a
senior team yesterday afternoon the one
topic that continue to be discussed was
the lack of clarity and the lack of a
mission and a description of what
exactly the Minnesota National Guard
needed to do my concern to the governor
was was twofold
one I didn't know what special equipment
I might need to accomplish the mission
and two I was very concerned about being
asked to move to an unfamiliar area of
Minneapolis under the cover of darkness
I wanted to get out when it was still
daylight where my soldiers in my Airmen
had become familiar with their terrain
and familiar with their mission we never
got such mission assignment we never got
such mission description yesterday we
perform four missions in support of the
governor's executive order the first
mission came from the governor directly
that came when we were notified of an
immediate and pending threat for the
State Capitol my immediate advice to the
governor was to assign that mission of
the Minnesota National Guard and he
agreed with one kind of caveat and that
is the State Patrol also wanted to
support that mission so in cooperation
with the State Patrol we began that
mission the second and third mission
came
together it came from st. Paul
specifically it was to provide security
of the Ramsey County Law Enforcement
Center in the Minnesota Bureau of
Criminal Apprehension the key part of
that security was to ensure that st.
Paul police officers were not required
to secure those facilities and they were
therefore relieved of that duty and able
to respond throughout the city of st.
Paul throughout the day and then the
last mission we did receive yesterday
evening was an escort mission for the
Minneapolis Fire Department the concept
of the operations that we would move
link up with the Minneapolis Police
Department and as they went into
unsecured and dangerous areas that we
would secure the area so they could
perform their life-saving and property
saving missions and we continued to do
those missions through the evening as
together indicated about quarter after
midnight this morning the governor
authorized a law-and-order mission into
the third Precinct what we would call
the military a clear and security
mission so under the leadership of the
State Patrol and the Department of
Public Safety the Minnesota National
Guard was assigned a task and a mission
in support of the State Patrol we would
follow the safe trope and we would help
secure the area that they cleared our
soldiers remain in that area as we as I
speak now still on that mission still
securing that location so people and
MnDOT can come in and begin the cleanup
of that area now we also have picked up
one other mission with the city of
Minneapolis I won't cover the exact
details but it's all going right now
with the Minneapolis Police Department
and I'm very proud of the relationship
between the Minnesota National Guard in
the Minneapolis Police Department that
goes back to Super Bowl 50 - just two
years ago chief Rondo and I were
during that superbowl so we we have had
opportunities to serve together and I
have a lot of respect for him we will
continue to operate in Minneapolis until
such time that the governor relieves us
of that mission and we will do so in
support of the Department of Public
Safety and the Minnesota State Patrol so
that's just a little bit of background
what the Minnesota National Guard since
just did since yesterday morning when we
first notified of a possible deployment
through the deployment and through our
mission set last night and then early
this morning my recommendation this
morning to the governor was that I
continued to do state capital mission
and that I continue to do the mission in
support of the Minneapolis Fire
Department I believe both of those are
very critical mission both to the state
and to Minneapolis and then we'll
conduct follow-on missions again in
support of the Minnesota State Patrol
and in the Department of Public Safety
so at this time I'd like to introduce
the Commissioner of the Department of
Public Safety Commissioner John
Harrington morning I'm John Harrington
I'm the question of the Department of
Public Safety governor Wolf's tasked me
to prepare options and capacities and
capabilities to respond to the civil
unrest protests but more importantly and
really more directly to the unlawful
behavior of the arsonist the thieves the
burglars the vandals who were tearing
apart the city of Minneapolis I'd want
that be clear that that's I think a
clear line of demarcation that we were
operating under because it is
fundamental to the Department of Public
Safety it is fundamental to the State
Patrol that we take an oath to support
the Constitution and that we believe
that our work is absolutely essential to
allow everyone
first amendment right to have their
voices heard
we were not deployed and we have not
been deployed and we will not be
deployed to stifle free speech but we
will not and cannot allow unlawful
dangerous behavior to continue I am
particularly proud of our relationship
with both the Minnesota National Guard
Commissioner Stroman from the Department
of Natural Resources and Colonel Langer
who works for the Department of Public
Safety as a colonel for the Minnesota
State Patrol we called and they came and
literally it was that it doesn't make it
much more complicated than that I said
I'm gonna need you and I'm gonna need
you here in the city and I'm gonna need
you for two or three days and I may need
you longer than that and I can't tell
you what I'm gonna need you to do yet
but I know I need you and they came they
began preparing readiness to be able to
move folks from all over the state of
Minnesota literally from miles and miles
away to come to the metro area to be
prepared to help us keep the peace over
the course of the day I met with my
counterparts in Minneapolis and st. Paul
chief Arredondo and she faxed Oh to talk
about what missions they needed the
state to help them fulfill the
department public safety at that point
was calling to say we are here to
support you we are your partners tell us
what you need and we will backfill we
will fill in the gaps you tell us what
you need for resources and we will help
you get it and we did get some very
specific missions and in other cases we
got no real mission at all and in the
absence of a real mission we began to
identify where the critical needs were
we tasked the State Patrol we test DNR
we tasked the Minnesota National Guard
to meet specific missions that we were
requested to do but we also task them
with being Fleck
because we knew that if things continue
to devolve that we might need to pivot
and we might need to shift from a static
post of Guardian critical infrastructure
to a fast-moving operational approach of
restoring order about midnight last
night I was party to a call where that
pivot had to be made where the mayor of
Minneapolis called and said they had no
more resources and they were not able to
meet the public safety needs and control
the behaviors that were occurring on
Lake Street they had lost the third
precinct there was concerns about a gas
main and there was concerns about
continued looting and fire was burning
throughout the city of Minneapolis and
different than our first night had
comparable concerns of looting and fires
being said in the city of st. Paul and
so we had to divide our resources to
meet the needs of both of the twin
cities the task the governor gave me was
pretty simple actually it was to pull
together a team that could go in keep
the peace protect people protect them
protect their safety protect their lives
protect their liberty and to protect
property that was being burned up
literally every minute that we delayed
the Hennepin County Sheriff was one of
my first calls and sheriff Hutchinson
immediately moved into action to give us
support we already had DNR we already
had State Patrol we already had missile
National Guard we had it available but
we hadn't asked them with what we needed
to do yet and we had to create a plan
the U of M police chief Matt Clark
offered support Eddie Frizzell the Chief
of Police for Metro Transit offered
support and with that team together we
put together a 200
the ballpark catcher a team to go in and
restore order on Lake Street you created
a mission it was very specific I am a
mission driven person we talked about
the fact that we were going to be
respectful of people's rights that we
were going to keep the peace and make
people safe and that we were going to
follow our training and protocols by
making a public announcement that they
needed to clear the streets and that if
they didn't clear the streets arrests
were imminent we made those announcement
we made those announcement repeatedly so
that no one would be confused about what
our intent was or what we were there to
do and then having made our
announcements we began to move to clear
those streets I will tell you that the
vast majority of the great people of
Minnesota and the great people of
Minneapolis who are who are still having
their guts ripped out about the Lloyd
murder and we'll call it a murder that's
what it looked like to me I don't want
to prejudice this from a criminal
perspective and I'm just calling it what
I see at that point they weren't the
people that were out there on the
streets at 3 o'clock in the morning when
we arrived on Lake Street the people
that were out there on Lake Street at 3
o'clock in the morning weren't the good
people in Minnesota and weren't the good
people in Minneapolis they weren't the
people that that wanted to mourn the
loss thing of a friend and a relative
and a neighbor and when they saw the
National Guard Minnesota State Patrol
and this Kaju a this team moving down
the street the vast majority of them did
what we thought they would do they left
there were a few that
decided not to leave that was a choice
that they get to make but we had advised
them what that choice would result in
and we took action to respectfully and
carefully take folks into custody as was
necessary and it was a very limited and
very structured and extremely
disciplined approach to making those
arrests I'm very proud of the fact that
despite what you've seen over the last
few days of gas and canisters and
foggers almost no chemical agent was
necessary to be used last night we did
it the old-fashioned way
command presence a uniform presence and
a clear intent to keep the peace restore
order and to keep people safe my task
today is a little different having
accomplished that mission and I think
we've secured those streets and I
appreciate the fact that I right now got
National Guard folks still holding that
ground that we took last night we need
to keep that ground and we need to
prepare for what may come today our task
today is we're bringing together a
unified command of Metro Area Police
Department Sheriff's Department's and
other law enforcement jurisdictions and
other public safety entities into a
multi-agency command center where we
will create a plan that will keep the
peace maintain the peace and prevent
further lawless behavior in the city of
Minneapolis the city of st. Paul and in
the surrounding suburbs we're going to
do this the right way we're going to do
it with full knowledge that our oath is
to serve SATA Minnesota to serve the
communities and to protect them we are
fully confident that we can do that
mission and that we can do it while
still ensuring that the constitutional
rights of those who need to have their
voices
and who needs a freely assemble can be
protected I can tell you that no one
could have heard mr. Lloyd's voice in
the chaos of the screaming and the
shouting and the fires at one o'clock in
the morning on Lake Street my job is to
make sure that tonight that the
community is safe and that our team is
ready and prepared keep it safe with
that I am very pleased to introduce the
colonel of the Minnesota State Patrol Oh
Matt Langer Oh Thank You commissioner my
name is Matt Langer and I have the honor
and privilege of serving as chief of the
Minnesota State Patrol I don't need to
rehash what the Commissioner went
through in terms of the detail that he
provided on the role of the Minnesota
State Patrol as it pertains to the city
of Minneapolis this week thinking about
what to say about this weak and
difficult is the first word that comes
to mind and it doesn't seem to represent
everything that has occurred this week
well enough but it certainly represents
the challenges that the Minnesota State
Patrol has faced the last couple of
nights as we have worked hard to combat
the lawlessness the dangerous behavior
and the criminal activity that has
occurred both in the city of Minneapolis
and other places let's speak
specifically the last night because as
you've heard shortly after midnight
between midnight and 1:00 a.m. governor
Wallace asked the State Patrol to lead
an event in the city of Minneapolis to
quell the unrest that was occurring in
and around the third Precinct there are
many challenges in that area one of the
main challenges in that area was a there
were fire as a set and the Minneapolis
Fire Department was unable to get there
and extinguish those fires because they
were shelled by those that were
demonstrating and choosing to make life
difficult for everyone who was trying to
improve the condition but the
Commissioner explained we assembled a
team both with the State Patrol the DNR
the University of Minnesota transit PD
and Napa County Sheriff's Office and the
National Guard and we assembled that
team quickly swiftly
strategically and we descended into the
city of Minneapolis with the one goal in
mind to as safely and quickly as
possible recover the ground that had
been lost
the lawless activity and make it safe
again and then restore order
clean the area and get it presentable so
that we can move into the future tonight
and Beyond with a much different picture
of what it means to be a resident
citizen and in your ability to
demonstrate peacefully that submission
that we took on that's what we did
overnight it was difficult dangerous
work for everyone involved the people
that are demonstrating those that are
caught in the middle of a demonstration
without the desire to demonstrate and
the first responders that are there
trying to do good work we had a few
troopers that suffered minor injuries
I'm thankful they're only minor they
stayed on the line and continued their
good work because we needed every single
one of them to do this job we remain
ready were there today with the National
Guard we're doing our best to hold that
ground well and to make sure that we
restore order clean that spot up the
better than it was before and to
continue our efforts to make sure that
Public Safety is of paramount concern as
we move forward both tonight and into
the future and then work together to
restore order across the entire city of
Minneapolis just as a side note we had a
couple missions other places last night
of course our responsibility at the
State Capitol and we also assisted the
city of st. Paul with some lawless
behavior that was occurring on
University Avenue with some of our
mobile response team assets one thing
I'll note is that we have troopers in
the metropolitan area from all across
the state of Minnesota that was an
opportunity that we afforded the
governor to make staffing boost that is
within the purview of the executive
branch and within the ability of State
Patrol to do on very short notice now my
hats off to those troopers that respond
to those DNR officers that responded
from all across the state of Minnesota
come for an unknown period of time and
to work very very hard to make Minnesota
what we believe it should be a safe
place for everybody thank you I would
note before we take questions and we'll
try and make sure we answer every
as many as you need to ask I would note
to the the reporters here in Minnesota
he was about three weeks ago I stood in
front of you and I as we passed five
under deaths by Koba 19 and said that on
about the 29th of May we would pass a
thousand that will happen today so in
the midst of this pandemic we are still
working that we believe again numbers
are down ICU bed capacity is stable and
we are doing everything we can and as
you heard from the folks speaking the
vast majority of people out there who
are expressing their First Amendment
rights and the rage over what happened
to George Floyd we're wearing Mouse and
we're trying their best to social
distance and not touch things I would
before I go to questions know that the
desire to get back to normal is so
overwhelming for everyone when so many
in Minnesota which said what else could
happen we've witnessed this but I think
it's an important time to pause about
that is the problem is for so many of us
thinking that normal is where we want to
go normal was not working for many
communities normal was not working for
George Floyd Priya Cove at 19 it's
certainly not working now and so I think
as you heard the Attorney General talk
about that work that we're trying to
look at to use this as a point in not
just rhetorically but a point to make
those changes with that Mary will start
[Music]
well I certainly don't think it's
important to be on on on TV I think what
you expected me to do is to be there is
we were in a support role as state law
shows and once we came apparent to me
that the city of Minneapolis would not
be able to complete that I was directing
the state to take that over this is my
responsibility well I think obviously if
you think I didn't that's probably the
case as a reporter but I think in the
moment of making sure as those decisions
were being made and that we were staying
in the lane that we were asked to
support this and as it deteriorated it
was at 12:05 there was a decision last
night that we made is to come in front
of you at that time because that was a
transition point because what you're
seeing now is the state is the lead
element now starting at 12:05 last night
and those first missions that were
carried out so I think for many of you
to know I try and make myself as
available as possible I think it was
important for me to be getting the data
and the feedback I was watching where
you were seeing and to be quite candid
when the when the third Precinct was
abandoned it seemed at that point in
time that that that was a time to move
so no I stayed in the residences where I
work from I have all the electronic
tools and we were on all night and as I
said we were we were taking calls and
adjusting and I was able to track as the
situation and evolved on going down
there was a dangerous task that I asked
the State Patrol the National Guard to
go down and take that those of you who
are watching that as I was as the
lawlessness was burning down the third
precinct or whatever that can't be
allowed to happen it did a little while
to plan this to get going that that's
where I was at to make sure it was
actually there were millions of
Americans and Minnesotans certainly
watching on their TV screens as this
unfolded last night there was almost a
complete lack of visibility of local
police state police National Guard after
much fanfare about how the National
Guard was coming in people watched
buildings burned public and private how
could there not have been a clear
mission for the National Guard when this
when they were called in and you knew
things we're gonna happen yeah I will
let my leadership come back up there
you're absolutely right and I think that
speaks to itself that by by shortly
after 10 o'clock it became apparent that
that structure would go the way this
works is as the mayor's asked and they
take charge and lead on the missions
I'll let the folks come up here said I
see that too I think the decision to
made to not engage and I want to just be
clear there's philosophically an
argument to be made that an armed
presence on the ground in the midst of
where
we just had a police killing is seen as
a catalyst my point to that was is we
don't need a catalyst it's already
burning and so this is trying to strike
that balance and so I am in total
agreement with that you will not see
that tonight there will be no lack of
leadership and there will be no lack of
response on the table National Guard
presence on every corner in those areas
last night as a deterrent as opposed to
having them come in this went up
potentially but the the decision on that
as it's made from the city and on this
one I I think I would agree with them we
saw the first night decisions were made
up until about 8:30 last evening it
appeared that things were relatively
peaceful on that there was a decision
during the day whether did you occupy
the entire city and shut it down after
those 24 hours in retrospect I'm
assuming that yes we would say that but
at the time and again we will not know
it because proving the negative would it
have simply started those that movement
faster and we've seen it moved out of
the third precinct but yes certainly
that's a it's a valid critique and point
yes communities is led by local
leadership their police force they were
at that time had sources in reserve they
were not being requested they were not
being requested and I'm on with them the
reason we're standing here today is if
this would have been executed correctly
the state would not lead on this the
state would have supported those and
they would have moved forward that did
not happen so now today we're taking
that we're making the decision to go and
do it moving forward and again I would
go back to Tom's question had I known
that we were not going to see that or
the capability to do it should the state
have come in potentially but I want to
be very clear this with the exception of
the state troopers who have a very
specific statutory requirement on the
highways order is to the local police
and sheriff's we do not have a built-in
police force General Jensen is not a
police force dps has experts in there
but these are not a police force that
are
they're streets with their people and so
that's a decision that was made it was
in reserve and and and yes
keeping in mind is this unfolded the
request came from st. Paul for the guard
to be activated at 5:00 I had moved on a
warning order earlier than that to be
prepared you're really supposed to wait
until you get that and start moving him
in that wasn't going to be possible
so by five o'clock yesterday our Guard
troops were coming from all over they
were getting activated because of the
events that happened the night before
and we were prepared to carry out those
missions and we were they were they were
there and as you heard some of these
folks in those missions never came again
as it relates emergency management in
Minnesota County emergency management
coordinators do exactly what you just
asked they define what they need and
what they want and then that's
negotiated with the state EEOC in the
Department of Public Safety along with
the agency they're asking for it's not
always the National Guard in this case
it is the National Guard the reason why
it's negotiated with Nash guard is to
make sure that we have the capability
the capability to do the mission that's
being asked so yes we are always in
support of the local leadership the the
local civilian leadership I have no
authority to self deploy the Minnesota
National Guard anywhere in the state I
have no authority whatsoever and so I
follow exactly what you laid out
civilian leadership civilian elected
officials make the request and then we
work with them because if I'm not
accomplishing their task and their
mission I risk failure of mission I also
risk the chance that I might break the
law right
I can't just March my soldiers down into
Minneapolis and say hey this is what Jon
Jensen believes we need to do that's not
how our government works and that's not
how our military responds and reports to
legitimate civilian leadership and so
what you asked is exactly right that's
exactly how it's supposed to work I
think that's quick you'll have to ask
mayor Frye the third was was not one
that I felt comfortable with and it's
one we discussed during the day so that
the potential that the third precinct
would not be held that's correct well
obviously that was the turning point
where we were prepared and that's where
we moved in that's where we did not
believe that the third should be given
up and that's why it's not in that area
was taken back by the force that we put
together starting at 12:15 executed
about 340 am i I simply think that this
I I'm like all of you watching it you
can't have civil order deteriorate and
then you have to make a calculated
decision about does forst going in there
escalate it does it stop it does it
endanger civilians and the force going
in there and those are decisions as you
heard again it is it is local police
departments as how this worked we are
not a police force to state we have
abilities to come back and backfill the
closest we have to that police force is
the State Patrol but that's not their
normal force to be able to go to because
again we're seeing it and there was no
definitive answer whether they were
going to and I'm seeing what you were
seeing there were still officers in the
third Precinct at least I believe until
maybe you can correct me on this till 9
o'clock or so maybe
curfews any sort of martial law workers
tools are there and I think what we'll
do is that's what's the planning stage
right now I don't want to take these
folks too long from what they're doing
that's what's being done over the last
you know 24 hours as we prepared for
this but once again the order structure
of this and many of us have been
involved in these I spent 24 years in
the National Guard myself I'm very
familiar of how these works I'm very
familiar with general Jensen's asking
about when my troops get their mission
they get their mission mortar they get a
warning order they know what they're
going to need to do I then as an
enlisted soldier would start working
with my troops to make sure they were
packing the proper equipment check it
out be ready to go drill through the
things we needed to do those never came
in many cases so I think if we'd have
seen two days ago yeah maybe maybe
yesterday I'll be the first to tell you
that I think in any of these things if
you're not if you're not second-guessing
and you if you're not looking at the
decisions were made you're going about
this all wrong I think the lessons
learned potentially so but again at that
time we've got to count on our partners
in this as they say things are going and
I'm not sure that quick-moving group of
anarchists that was moving so quickly
one of the things we said if you think
about this to prevent this from
happening like at the Super Bowl or the
RNC 18 months of planning went into that
18 months of planning and pre
positioning 18 months of joint powers
agreement 18 months of lining up the
materials that were there to make sure
all those situations could be there
because my situation on this is once you
lose control like that I'm deeply
concerned that the bad actors and I want
to be very clear we own this we own this
in Minnesota but there certainly as
people saw this unfold the concern was
yesterday how many people would make
their way here who are simply in that
business so yeah I think it's a valid
question I think for me as I look at
that the point is I have to operate in
real space in in real time and by last
evening was the second day we saw it and
from 8:30 or or during the day until
8:30 we did see this in st. Paul we
continued to
what was happening in st. Paul the State
Patrol was tasked on many of this and
they did stop a lot of that along the
target and some of those that was what
was being asked from them but it
happened from about 8:30 at night when
the Sun went down when what I saw was
the person breaching the barrier at the
third and then the decision to pull back
out of there
so who hasn't asked I got to make sure I
get to everybody governor so it sounds
like you are going to allow
demonstrations tonight protests and
stuff these would be in violation of
standing orders against congregations of
more than 10 people no we're not
allowing any of those and we've said it
I think the idea again the absurdity in
the middle of kovat 19 where we have
worked so dang hard as a state to keep
people from congregating if you think
you could but it goes back to this
conversation we've had in Minnesota this
takes a social compact of people who
agreeing to do this and I want to just
say this watching what happened to
George Floyd had people say to hell with
staying home on that I'm going out
because this can't happen again the idea
that we would go in there and break up
those peaceful expressions of grief and
rage was ridiculous the problem was of
not having in place with an expectation
that a crowd that big over such a
volatile issue we have seen this happen
in City after City whether it was
Ferguson whether it was LA we've seen
these things that was the thing like we
started planning started asking but
again you're seeing holes in planning
that's for darn sure estates and cities
and counties on these things start to
happen right now and we certainly this
is the plan that'll be presented to me I
think we want to be prepared to present
that to to Minnesotans here by two
o'clock or so what I can tell you is a
lot of it is going to be the operational
things that you would expect to happen
that we're asked they will be there
there will be a presence out on on the
corners we will start to do that but I'm
going to ask again I need to ask
Minnesotans those in pain and those who
feel like justice has not been served
yet you need to help us create this
space so that that justice will be
served and it's my
expect a shin that it'll be Swift and
that we're able to maintain that order
and so that plan will start to happen
today and it will include we will think
of all the tools that are there I want
to come back to that again the more of
those things you use the more those are
viewed as the oppressive things that led
to much of this in the first place what
we're trying to separate is the lawful
First Amendment aggrieved citizens who
need to express that from the folks who
are clearly I'm telling you what the
farthest thing from people's on their
minds as they're burning down a
family-owned store at 3:00 a.m. on Lake
Street was George Floyd and and that's
what we've got to get at candidly I
don't think this is a secret to anybody
that the tension between the Minneapolis
Police Department and many of their
communities is is a pretty well-known
thing and and I am certainly I don't
know any way to express it other than
that they had lost faith in them and
felt that they were part of the problems
and certainly seeing a uniformed
Minneapolis Police officers knee on
George Floyd's neck on Monday pretty
much tells you where the public is
thinking towards that so I don't think
you could think it was a mistake of who
was leading that down there and that it
changed the tone that was there so I am
concerned I think it would be
disingenuous I know this is painful this
is hard there is going to be
recriminations there's going to be going
back and looking at this as there should
be my top priority now is the immediate
security to make sure that what happened
the last 48 hours does not happen
tonight the state of Minnesota has
assumed that responsibility I don't
think it's going to be easy because this
whole whack Amole thing and these folks
are really good at what they were trying
to do on causing destruction the way
we're able to stop it is employ these
tools with the support of the public to
make sure we isolate these folks and and
again as missioner hearing concede the
idea that you think you can
firebomb a building and not be arrested
and spent serious time in jail I
understand that but the idea that we
don't want to make people who are out
there still asking what about George
Floyd what happened to those people what
happened to the people who did this that
got lost in 48 hours of anarchy that's
what we're gonna put again we saw three
television journalists get arrested
early this morning on live television
can you or anyone up there tell me how
many looters and arsonists have been
arrested over the past two days in the
Twin Cities I'm gonna use this as an
opportunity again as I said Tom I am
deeply apologetic that this happened I
understand that the community would
believe if this were targeted I as I
told Jeff Zucker the president of CNN I
don't care at this point what the
circumstance was why they got arrested
it is wrong it is unacceptable we needed
to correct it as far as others who can
answer yeah yes of st. Paul and State
Patrol and others have made arrests on
burglary arson charges I believe arson
charges
I know burglary for sure that they have
been arrested there has been stops there
has been in fact folks incarcerated I do
not know how they've been charged yet or
not because I think most of them were
done in the last 24 hours
yes it's breaking into the breaking into
the the grocery stores breaking into the
targets breaking into the the Walgreens
some of the pharmacies have been just
decimated with folks we believe who are
seeking oxy cotton and other opioids out
of the pharmacy stock and so we've been
chasing that around as well as chasing
the folks that have been setting fires
so yes there have been arrests made and
there will be more arrests made if again
I will get you a number I don't have
that I asked the the both Minneapolis
st. Paul and my other folks that were
part of our our unified command to get
me information by 10 o'clock or 11
o'clock this morning I have not received
it yet but I'm hopeful to have a sitrep
from the last 24 hours
and we'll get that to you as soon as I
get it
well it's not helpful I did speak to the
president last evening at that point in
time it was in the process of where I
said we were going to assume control of
this that it was it was unnecessary I
did not know he was going to tweet he
certainly can it's just not helpful it's
not helpful the the city of Minneapolis
is doing everything they can if mistakes
are made and there's an accountability
we need to do that but in the moment
where we're at in a moment that is so
volatile anything we do to to add fuel
to that fire is is really really
challenging so as I said I spoke to the
president he pledged his support of
anything we need in terms of supplies to
get to us there's a way to do this
without in flaming and again this one is
so difficult as I said again the tools
of restoring order are viewed by so many
as the things that have oppressed and
started this problem in the first place
so it would just be more helpful at this
point in time we may if we need support
from them it's certainly appropriate
that we will ask but at this point in
time I'm confident that the plan we put
together today to restore this order to
bring
I think maybe this is a commissioner
Harrington and and Attorney General
Ellison when we first came into office
last year this was one of the things we
wanted and I said this a as a governor
the the nightmare scenario of having a
police involved shooting or as any
elected official as one so they started
working this I think I'll hear from well
governor thank you I think this really
is the time to start talking about how
we do meaningful deep-dive reform we
took a year to grab in a number of
people from diverse interests in the
community we had people from the
community from the civil rights
community we had law enforcement there
we had law enforcement from across the
state we met for about a year we had a
professional assistance from the group
that guided the 21st century policing
process that governor and that President
Obama started and we came up with a
number of key recommendations we will
get that report to you we hope you write
about it but we now but this
supercharges the need for the effort
there was just a few recommendations
well a few observations and a few
recommendations one observation is you
know a lot of deadly force encounters
that occur in our state are not
concentrated in the Twin Cities in fact
a majority of them were in it when
Greater Minnesota although many were in
the Twin Cities half of them were people
in the mental health crisis we talk in
in in we also so we talked about a
number of things we talked about officer
wellness officers dealing from crisis to
crisis to crisis need to be able to
check in get right before they go back
and engage the public we talked about
changing and reviewing the standard the
use of force standard we talked about
making the sanctity of life essential
principle which mayor Hodges did when
she was the mayor we made duty to
intervene they were recommending that be
essential meaning if you're a police
officer you see a fellow officer doing
something wrong you cannot just say it's
not me you've got to do something about
it we came up with a number of other
principles that I think I really
helpful very useful involving training
reform at the post board and a number of
things and I think that now there's a
need to further the effort I will say
that I think that looking at systemic
pattern and practice problems in
Minneapolis Police Department is an
appropriate conversation at this time I
think that we need to really do some
deep dive in to make sure that you know
that our law enforcement professionals
will really do and really really are
serving the public the whole public so I
will say that I hope that our state
legislature takes up some of the
initiatives that we have in there the
academic community will take up some of
it training communities will take up
some of it I mean a dual one of the
recommendations was a dual a joint or
dual response when there are chemical or
mental health crises going on so that
it's not just officers that don't have
the training on how to deal with
somebody who's in that situation so that
is that's a priority and I'll hand it to
Commissioner Harrington general Ellison
covered that really most of the points
that the one other point that I will
bring in is that this group was very
much based out of community we brought
in folks from a variety of different
diverse and geographic communities we
brought in folks from the disability
community to make sure that all all
kinds of voices were heard and one of
the voices that I heard most clearly was
the need for community healing and
community health and and so one of the
recommendations that we have put forward
we still think is what it was important
before but I've never seen it as acutely
as important as it is right now is for
community healing the question that we
asked and that I asked here with you is
how does the community recover when it's
heart has been ripped out that's
[Music]
we are working with the county attorney
who is the charging authority to make
sure that we are following their
guidance as we move forward in seeking
the criminal prosecution investigation
and so I can't speak to much more than
that other than the past practice for
the Bureau of Criminal Apprehension and
most Police Department's has been in
these kind of cases they work with the
county attorney to make sure that they
have checked all the eyes and all the
t's and made sure everything is in order
before they make an arrest or before
there's a charging decision and we have
been following that protocol with county
attorney Freeman in this case we have
him history with county attorney Freeman
in terms of past cases some successful
some not successful depending on on what
your perspective is so we there is
certainly a sentiment that it's
different
but from the point of view of the law we
have a we have a man whose life has been
ended we have this pursuit of trying to
find out what were the facts that are
surround that and to be able to create
enough probable cause or enough enough
basis for a criminal charge or for an
arrest that is that's pretty much cop
101 that that's what you have to have
and that's what we are working toward
in Minneapolis that have been affected
by this and Occidental stay 2020 their
life and number two we've been moving
people out of detention because it's
co-ed if there are significant arrests
do we have a place to put phones because
of the offer well yeah I mean listen to
law enforcement on this one they these
are great questions that's ones that we
came up with to that the what's going to
happen my hope is and again hope is not
a plan you need to execute that but I
think with Minnesotans understand what's
at stake here and getting back to the
focus of George Floyd in our community
issues that tonight needs to be
different and when I say that it needs
to be different in the questions you're
asking I'm stepping into that breach and
this is the responsibility of states
responding we'll use what we have we'll
use the tools and and so hopefully on
that side all that's John if he wants to
on her s sure I think this is certainly
something we we still did not finish our
work in the regular session I think
we're coming back on the 12th probably
and and working with the legislature I
think there's a great desire to figure
out how to do this the the tragedy of
this as I said again is a community that
that felt this tragedy a community that
believes that they were that this has
happened to a community when we say
sometimes I hear people sometimes say
the the system is the system's broken
and all no communities of color will say
oh no the system's working just fine for
certain people not us and I think for us
right now we need to take a really hard
look about reinvesting bringing Lake
Street back making sure we're hoping
that there is insurance for these folks
different things that we can do but I
think certainly getting our vitality
back is one
so the first question are they armed yes
they are currently armed a little
background on that yesterday afternoon
we received what I assess is a credible
threat specifically to the Minnesota
National Guard that credible threat was
made available to us by the FBI I shared
that with with Governor walls along with
my recommendation that I felt as though
it was a credible threat and as a result
that we should arm the Minnesota
National Guard governor Walz concurred
with me and authorized me to arm the
Minnesota National Guard now what are
the limits of their use of force we
traditionally don't talk about the use
of force because it's a it's an
operational issue but I will tell you
this our Guardsmen maintain the right to
self-defense and and I think that's
where I'm going to leave it as it
relates to to the use of force for the
Minnesota National Guard thank you
talk about protecting the State Capitol
were they referring to the state capitol
building and are you concerned that that
building needs to be protected and then
as a follow-up when will you make a
decision on a curfew for tonight
hopefully around two o'clock Tom I'll
try and give it I'll give you that so
you know give us a little bit of time as
they're finalizing on this but I think
that's one of the questions yes the and
we had brought up the Capitol building
before of that these very symbolic
targets that that people had talked
about the folks who who had some of it
was online you saw the thing that came
in that's the one request that I made of
the National Guard and the mission that
I'm asking for specifically on our
troops that came in before the cities
needed to ask for what they needed was
the the preservation of the Capitol and
the end the Capitol grounds and so that
will still maintain that will still be
in force we they are and they have been
yeah that's exactly right
yeah I certainly think and I'm not going
to speculate we'd ask them I think
probably the assumption is there's folks
that come in but as I said earlier we
need to make sure that we own this the
thing that sparked this is is a
homegrown Minnesota thing the event that
sparked it know that I I think I think I
think we can't tell that right now but I
think much of how a lot of this happened
certainly all of the things that have
led to this this is mrs. Minnesota I
think we need to find out I don't think
it changes the calculus that much of how
do we got to this how do we respond to
it no I didn't say fry on this I said my
my issues like this and I will
extensibility if the if the issue was is
that the state should have moved faster
yeah that is on me whether it's the
forces that were underneath so I don't
think a lack of leadership I think the
lack of coordination and the lack of
understanding what we needed to ask for
and again that's in retrospect that same
I think that same criticism could be
said to us but the the way things are
lined up that was their responsibility
at that point now it's our
responsibility to do that and I think
we've been in contact with the mayor's I
think they are doing everything they
possibly can in a situation that is is
unprecedented i I don't think again
that's a cop out of saying let's just
unprecedented that doesn't mean you
can't do anything about it
but I think they're responding
accordingly I think we're we're learning
a lot as I said these situations were
planned for at the RNC and 18 months of
planning and hundreds of millions of
dollars this came about after the
killing of George Floyd on Monday night
it started to ramp up when the video
came out on Tuesday it accelerated into
Wednesday and Thursday
and here we set over back when people
don't understand is the difference
between types of crimes meaning mr.
Floyd is not going to be released on the
street pending an investigation and
subsequent charges why if you have seen
what you have concluded from your eyes
to be a murder isn't someone arrested
pending the completion of the
investigation and pending charges that
the authority to arrest and hold and in
turn typically in a in a situation where
you have have actually witnessed a crime
and you are you have the immediate you
are immediately able to apprehend the
suspect
it would be not unusual to have made an
arrest brought that person in and then
offered to the county attorney what you
were able to cobble together in terms of
information to seek a criminal charge if
there was no criminal charge because you
did not have sufficient information then
the person is released pending further
investigation in this case because there
was a lag time between when the video
when the event occurred when the video
became out and when DCA was then brought
into this there was not that same
immediacy and so a criminal
investigation was initiated by the BCA
very quickly working in coordination
with Amy Sweezey from the Hennepin
County Attorney's Office to follow the
protocols that Tony Turner and Freeman
has outlined that he wants us to follow
in terms of a officer-involved death
case so we are following the protocols
that that were established we continue
to follow those protocols we continue to
meet with the county attorney we
continue to meet with the FBI and the US
attorney as we continue to seek justice
and to see what what can we do and what
are we allowed to do in in bringing this
case to a conclusion general Jenson
quick one do you have to do the
have authority to arrest and detain no
we do not have that authority
that's why typically in our missions
we'll always have a law enforcement
officer with us so we have that assume
that support immediately available but
no we don't I can't assure you but the
responsibility to ensure it doesn't
happen falls upon me and I will do
everything in my power to do that as I
said I I spent myself 24 years in the
National Guard I'm surrounded by by good
people we're pulling the assets in I'm
gonna need the help of Minnesotans like
we do on a lot of this I'm gonna need
folks to cooperate to get this through I
want to acknowledge again that pain that
people are feeling they need to get to
get justice I'm gonna I'm just going to
respond to Peters question too on this
Peter because it was an excellent
question asking about the charges and
things for those of you know I am NOT an
attorney I listen to them and and
they're very they're very concerned that
that the governor has to be very careful
about what they say about prejudicing
case we want to make sure everybody gets
justice it gets done but the questions
that Minnesotans and the outrage they're
feeling I'm feeling them it is taking
all of my willpower to to maintain that
point of being asked but the way I'm
able to get them justice is by making
sure that I put things in place that
civil order is maintained that we make
it clear that there is an expectation
that justices is move forward and as
attorney general Ellison says this is a
point in time that we cannot forget
cannot forget George we cannot forget
the aftermath of this as if we would but
we have to get back to that point of
what caused this all to happen and start
working on that so the the anger and the
frustration and the wondering why this
is this is a community that ERF
year decade after decade and generation
after generation here's this so right
now I know there's a lot of folks out
there listening that their answer should
be I'll believe it when I see it I'll
believe it when justice is carried out
I'll believe it when equity actually
means something I'll believe it when the
policies change I'll believe it when my
child gets the same education as your
child and that that color didn't matter
so I get it right now we're asking an
awful lot to be based on faith and that
has not panned out but I do want to say
this is a state that we again I think we
are coming to grips with the good that
we have and that that's not there but
it's always been about trying to strive
to be better trying to do more I'm not
trying to sugarcoat this just much like
Cove at 19 I've had to stand in front of
you and tell you that it's going to get
worse before it gets better
this is not going to be an easy journey
but the one thing that we have to ensure
that civil order is maintained so those
changes we want to see none of us can
live in a society where roving bands go
unchecked and do what they want to do
ruin property and that the expectation
is where are the police where the police
and this is the conundrum where the
police in the first place got us in this
situation Monday night and where are the
police last night is it and I heard from
numerous people I'm super nervous about
the National Guard being brought in
there it's a flashpoint this cyka mean I
understand that I heard from some of
those same people at two o'clock with a
different tone where's the National
Guard where is the National Guard so
over these next 24 to 48 hours work with
us to get the situation controlled and I
want to talk to those mayor's who are up
24-7 in Minneapolis and st. Paul
it's not about calling out someone on
lack of leadership it's about an issue
as it developed in all of us figuring
out how we get there
this is volatile this has been building
for decades this flashpoint came to us
and now what are we going to do about it
and it happened in the middle of an
unprecedented global pandemic so it
gives us a chance we're gonna get to
pick our paths very quickly here how are
we going to be seen by the world in the
coming days how are we going to be seen
after that how are we going to respond
to one
and then what are we gonna do about it
and again if I were everybody in these
communities listening I'd say well I'm
gonna believe it when I see it so the
first task at hand is its civil control
back get justice moving quickly and
fairly and start talking about together
how do we rebuild how do we rebuild
trust in the police how do we rebuild
those stores how do we rebuild a society
how do we send that face to the world
that sees us for so many positive things
but we need to recognize this is what
they're seeing and we need to take a
hard look and figure out how do we
change that so I want to thank you all
again I'm going to close because of the
importance I've said with the with the
press deepest apologies to the to the
reporters that were out there
expectations that again that cannot
happen we will do our best today and I
would ask all of you as the ongoing
mission to make sure that we have peace
and security today is making sure that
that story is told I'm asking our team
to make sure that crept press
credentials the ability to move you and
protect you safely needs to be out there
so this is covered please let us know
quickly on that please make sure that
that's happening please show the world
everything that's happening here through
that lens of professional journalists
who asks the questions you're asking
today so thank you all